- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous et bienvenue dans "Parlement
hebdo", l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement avec vous, Kathia
Gilder.
- Kathia Gilder: Laurent
Jacobelli, vous êtes député
Rassemblement national de Moselle.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les députés
débattent de la lutte contre les
squatteurs.
Une proposition vise à durcir les
sanctions contre l'occupation
illicite de logements.
La majorité de droite du Sénat
approuve la hausse des moyens des
forces de l'ordre de la justice,
mais rejette le budget dédié à
l'immigration.
La commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur l'ingérence des
puissances étrangères dans les
parties.
- Kathia Gilder: Elisabeth Borne a
dévoilé cette semaine les
premières mesures de la réforme
des retraites.
Il y aura bien un recul progressif
de l'âge de départ à la retraite à
65 ans d'ici à 2031.
Une retraite minimale à 1200 euros
et la fin des régimes spéciaux.
Laurent Jacobelli, est-ce que les
députés RN sont toujours opposés à
cette réforme?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Complètement.
Je suis choqué par cette
déclaration dans Le Parisien.
C'est étonnant, de découvrir les
grandes lignes de cette réforme en
lisant la presse.
Le gouvernement ne veut pas
travailler avec le Parlement et
les députés, parce qu'il n'a pas
la majorité absolue.
Ce gouvernement est entêté et
obtus.
Il déteste les contre-propositions
et l'opposition.
Je me demande si madame Elisabeth
Borne s'est fait greffer une
calculette à la place du coeur.
Le modèle de retraite des Français
est un modèle solidaire, et elle
veut en faire un modèle performant
économiquement.
Si c'est le cas, au moment où on
se parle, 1 Français sur 2 arrive
à la retraite en étant au chômage
ou en invalidité.
Décaler la retraite dans le temps,
ce sera décaler d'autant le nombre
de subventions-chômage, le nombre
de mois au RSA ou le nombre de
mois en pension d'invalidité.
Tout cela n'a aucun sens, ni
socialement, ni économiquement.
- Alexandre Poussart: Comment
équilibrer ce déficit des
retraites?
- Laurent Jacobelli: On s'est
aperçu, cette année, que les
caisses sont plus pleines qu'on
nous l'avait annoncé.
Le comité d'orientation des
retraites nous dit que, vers 2030,
nous serons à l'équilibre.
Donc pour quelques années
difficiles, on va casser un modèle
social?
C'est l'inverse, qu'il faut faire.
Il faut promettre la retraite à 60
ans quand on commence avant 20
ans.
- Kathia Gilder: Le gouvernement
ment, en promettant un déficit
abyssal, si rien n'est fait?
- Laurent Jacobelli: C'est faux.
Au mieux, s'il y a une once de
vérité dans la parole de madame
Borne et du gouvernement, on va un
peu renflouer les caisses de
retraite, mais aggraver les
caisses chômage et les caisses de
la Sécurité sociale.
Les Français ne partent pas à la
retraite en ayant un emploi, une
fois sur deux.
Le problème, c'est l'emploi des
seniors.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
vous appelez les Français à
descendre dans la rue contre cette
réforme des retraites?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Ils doivent
savoir que ce gouvernement n'est
pas là pour les aider et qu'il
n'obéit pas aux Français, mais à
Bruxelles.
Pourquoi on fait cette réforme des
retraites?
Le plan de relance, financé par
Bruxelles, pour sortir de la crise
que nous traversons, a une clause
qui impose à la France de faire
une réforme des retraites.
Pour être simple, quand on donne
100 euros à l'UE, elle nous en
rend 65, et elle met des
conditions.
C'est perdant-perdant.
- Kathia Gilder: L'Assemblée s'est
penchée sur la question des
squatteurs.
- Défendre les propriétaires dont
les maisons sont squattées, c'est
l'objectif du député Renaissance
qui veut passer les sanctions à 3
ans d'emprisonnement pour les
squatteurs et 45.000 euros
d'amende.
- J'ai impression que certains
veulent défendre les squats,
allonger les procédures ou ne
veulent pas parler de ces
propriétaires en difficulté, au
simple motif qu'ils sont
propriétaires.
Celles et ceux d'entre vous qui
ont reçu dans leur permanence un
citoyen dont le domicile est
squatté ou un propriétaire dont le
bien est occupé par un locataire
qui ne paye plus depuis des années
savent que cette situation ne peut
plus durer.
- Guillaume Kasbarian propose de
raccourcir les délais d'expulsion.
- On essaye de médiatiser des
situations scandaleuses et
gravissimes.
La violation de domicile prévoit
tout un arsenal juridique.
- Les Républicains et le
Rassemblement National soutiennent
la proposition de Renaissance.
- Vous opposez les honnêtes gens
qui payent votre faillite sur le
logement à de gens qui ont investi
dans un logement et qui sont
victimes d'un laxisme judiciaire.
- Le texte prévoit d'inclure une
clause de résiliation de plein
droit pour accélérer l'expulsion
en cas de loyers impayés.
- Kathia Gilder: La dernière loi
qui régit les expulsions date de
2020.
Qu'apporte cette nouvelle
proposition de loi, selon vous?
Est-ce que ce texte a été fait
sous la pression des médias et des
affaires médiatiques?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Je ne le
pense pas.
Le texte de 2020 n'était qu'un
brouillon inefficace.
Le gouvernement s'est rendu compte
que ce qu'il avait fait voter ne
fonctionnait pas.
Il y a encore des gens qui ont
peur de partir en vacances parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas trouver chez
eux une famille qui a squatté.
Il y a des gens qui refusent
d'investir pour louer parce qu'ils
pensent que c'est trop risqué.
Pour relancer le logement, il faut
une loi anti-squatteurs.
Aujourd'hui, le squatteur est plus
détendu que le propriétaire.
Un propriétaire qui veut récupérer
son bien risque trois fois plus de
peines que le squatteur.
Il faut rééquilibrer tout ça.
Il manque quand même un volet
important dans ce projet de loi,
c'est comment faire appliquer la
loi, le volet opérationnel.
Il n'est pas inscrit dans cette
loi.
Comment le préfet met en place les
moyens pour déloger les
squatteurs?
Cette gauche, qui a eu ses heures
de gloire dans le social, est
devenue une gauche indigne.
La gauche qui défend les voleurs
par rapport aux honnêtes gens...
La gauche qui défend ceux qui
volent la propriété par rapport
aux petits épargnants...
Une gauche déboussolée, qui défend
aujourd'hui les voyous et accuse
les victimes.
Les petits propriétaires ne sont
pas des profiteurs.
Les squatteurs ne sont pas des
pauvres gens, ce sont des
délinquants.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mais ceux
que vous appelez "voyous", est-ce
que ce ne sont pas des victimes du
mal-logement?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Je suis
choqué par cet argument.
Choqué que l'on puisse penser que
des gens qui sont en situation
difficile n'ont comme seul
objectif que de violer la loi et
de squatter la propriété d'autrui.
Beaucoup de Français vivent dans
une situation difficile, mais sont
honnêtes.
J'ai du mal avec cette excuse que
trouve la gauche, en disant que
ceux qui ont des difficultés sont
amenés à voler ou à squatter.
La plupart sont honnêtes.
J'en connais, dans ma
circonscription.
Il y a un problème de logement,
dans notre pays.
Il serait temps de mettre en place
la priorité nationale.
Que les Français aient la priorité
sur le logement social.
Il y a une surreprésentation des
familles étrangères dans
l'occupation des habitations à
loyer modéré.
Les Français qui respectent la loi
doivent avoir la priorité sur le
logement.
Dans le placement dans les
logements sociaux, il y a une
sorte de préférence étrangère.
- Kathia Gilder: Deux autres
projets de loi étaient proposés
par vos collègues Républicains
pour faciliter l'expulsion des
étrangers délinquants.
Ils ont été rejetés.
Est-ce que vous espérez qu'elle
figure dans le projet de Gérard
Darmanin?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Je n'attends
rien de Gérald Darmanin.
C'est l'homme qui a laissé 230
migrants arriver par l'Ocean
Viking et qui n'a pas pu arrêter
l'imam Iquioussen.
Il ne réglera ni le problème de la
sécurité ni celui de
l'immigration.
Ce qu'il s'est passé cette semaine
à l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
proposition de loi des
Républicains est terrifiant.
La NUPES a dit que même si c'était
un criminel terroriste, un migrant
devait rester en France, quoi
qu'il en coûte sur la sécurité de
nos concitoyens.
Le gouvernement lui a emboîté le
pas.
Dès les premières minutes, il a
voté cette proposition de la NUPES
pour casser la proposition des
Républicains.
Il y a eu un accord de fait.
Ce gouvernement n'accepte pas que
les oppositions puissent faire des
propositions et puissent gagner
une bataille au sein du Parlement.
Tous les moyens sont bons: le
49.3, le dépôt d'amendements
fantaisistes et même l'alliance
avec l'extrême gauche radicale,
qui défendra toujours les
migrants, mêmes criminels.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le
gouvernement et Gérald Darmanin
sont favorables à la double peine
pour les étrangers délinquants.
Ils veulent introduire cela dans
le futur projet de loi sur
l'immigration.
Ca va dans le bon sens?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Gérald
Darmanin montre les muscles, mais
au premier semestre 2021, le taux
des OQTF était historiquement bas.
Il a accueilli l'Ocean Viking,
alors que plus personne ne veut de
ce type de bateaux, qui sont des
bateaux-taxis vers l'Europe.
Il a tous les records en matière
de laxisme et prétend régler le
problème?
Nous avons une solution: un projet
de loi aux Français et leur
demander leur avis par référendum.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous voteriez ce
projet de loi ou vous n'en voulez
pas?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Il va falloir
le lire.
- Kathia Gilder: Il sera présenté
en février au Sénat et en mars à
l'Assemblée.
- Laurent Jacobelli: La seule
chose concrète pour l'instant,
c'est la régularisation des
sans-papiers qui travaillent.
- Alexandre Poussart: Grégoire De
Fournas est revenu à l'Assemblée
deux semaines après avoir tenu ces
propos polémiques dans le
l'hémicycle.
- Laurent Jacobelli: L'hémicycle a
toujours été un ring de boxe.
Il en a été victime.
Il a dit que les bateaux qui
arrivaient d'Afrique pour amener
des migrants clandestins en France
devaient retourner dans leur pays
d'origine.
C'est, je crois, ce que pense une
majorité de Français.
La manière d'exprimer a été
énergique et a été détournée par
la NUPES.
Le gouvernement s'est engouffré
dans la brèche pour faire du buzz.
L'hémicycle est malheureusement un
lieu de joutes verbales pour faire
le buzz.
Pour eux, on est comme à une grève
générale.
Il faut leur faire appliquer le
règlement et pas seulement à
l'encontre des députés du
Rassemblement National.
Il y a un deux poids, deux
mesures, qui devient inquiétant.
- Pas de désaccord sur les budgets
régaliens.
Le Sénat a voté à une large
majorité une hausse des crédits
sécurité de 1,25 milliards d'euros
proposé par le gouvernement pour
l'année 2023.
Elle doit permettre de financer la
modernisation numérique des forces
de l'ordre et de renouveler leur
équipement.
La majorité sénatoriale a approuvé
une hausse de 8% du budget du
ministère de la Justice.
710 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seront débloqués
en 2023 pour permettre des
recrutements dans les tribunaux et
des places de prison.
- Certains diront que ce n'est
jamais assez, mais c'est plus que
cela n'a jamais été.
- Les sénateurs ont rejeté le
budget immigration.
Le gouvernement prévoyait une
augmentation pour l'an prochain.
Pas assez pour la gauche, et trop
pour la droite.
- Nous traitons les problèmes au
fil de l'eau.
- La droite sénatoriale a rejeté
une augmentation du budget de
l'aide médicale d'Etat aux
étrangers en situation
irrégulière.
Le gouvernement prévoyait une
augmentation de 133 millions
d'euros.
Le Sénat a préféré voter une
baisse de 350 millions d'euros et
a restreint le périmètre de cette
aide aux seuls soins d'urgence.
- L'AME constitue une exception
difficile à justifier par rapport
aux pays voisins.
Seuls certains soins d'urgence
sont pris en charge gratuitement
pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière.
- Une restriction votée contre
l'avis du gouvernement et des
groupes de gauche.
Les désaccords pourront être
tranchés par une commission mixte
paritaire entre députés et
sénateurs ou par un nouveau
recours du gouvernement au 49.3
pour une adoption sans vote à
l'Assemblée nationale.
- Alexandre Poussart: La majorité
de droite du Sénat a rejeté le
budget dédié à l'asile et à
l'immigration.
Les sénateurs ont bien fait?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Il faut aller
plus loin.
Ce serait open bar à l'hôpital, y
compris pour les migrants
clandestins?
Il faut réduire l'enveloppe pour
un dispensaire d'urgence.
Bien sûr, on ne laisse pas
quelqu'un mourir ou diffuser une
maladie.
Sinon, les migrants se feront
soigner tout: les yeux, les
dents...
Mais il est évident que ce budget
va faire l'objet d'un 49.3.
Il est mal tricoté.
Ce qu'il manque, c'est de l'argent
pour la police et la justice.
C'est surtout une volonté.
Tant qu'il y aura Eric
Dupond-Moretti à la justice, rien
ne changera.
- Kathia Gilder: Reconnaissez que
le gouvernement fait des efforts
pour les forces de l'ordre.
- Laurent Jacobelli: Mais il faut
qu'il y ait des peines.
Faites une patrouille avec les
gendarmes, comme je l'ai fait.
Ils vous diront: "Lui, c'est un
trafiquant de drogue.
Lui, il a agressé sa femme."
Ils pourront une nouvelle fois les
arrêter et ils seront une nouvelle
fois libérés.
Ce n'est pas seulement parce que
les tribunaux sont engorgés.
C'est vrai, mais c'est aussi parce
qu'il y a une logique de l'excuse
et de la repentance générale qui
fait que les voyous sont victimes
et que les victimes sont ignorées.
Il faut revoir notre système.
J'en ai assez d'entendre que la
police tue et serait dans une
forme de criminalité.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous entendez
cela dans l'hémicycle?
- Laurent Jacobelli: La gauche et
la NUPES ne cessent de le répéter.
Ils sont dans un schéma d'un autre
siècle.
Ils le font par électoralisme.
Ils visent une forme de
communautarisme et ils nient une
évidence: le lien entre
immigration et sécurité.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat a
voté la semaine dernière sur
l'ensemble du budget.
A l'Assemblée nationale, vous
n'avez pas eu la possibilité de
modifier ce texte.
Avec le passage en force du
gouvernement...
Cela se généralise?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Jupiter n'a
pas accepté qu'il y ait une
contradiction dans son propre pays
et le verdict des urnes.
Aujourd'hui, le gouvernement est
sous tutelle des oppositions, qui
sont là pour contrôler, observer
et rediriger l'action du
gouvernement.
Et ça, il ne l'accepte pas.
Jupiter est devenu Narcisse.
Madame Borne est son agent
exécutant.
Elle vient une fois par semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale nous
expliquer que notre travail est à
jeter à la poubelle, que nos
électeurs n'ont pas voix au
chapitre et qu'ils feront ce
qu'ils veulent.
Ce mépris du Parlement a laissé la
place à des méthodes un peu moins
nobles.
Le dépôt de sous-amendements en
masse, pour faire capoter un
projet de loi de l'opposition, des
alliances contre nature avec
l'extrême gauche radical, pour
empêcher des lois qui vont vers
plus de sécurité et de contrôle de
l'immigration...
- Kathia Gilder: Pensez-vous qu'il
faille une dissolution?
- Laurent Jacobelli: Cette menace
n'inquiète que Les Républicains.
C'est le parti qui pourrait en
être le plus victime et qui est
donc parfois amené à faire le dos
rond par rapport aux demandes du
gouvernement.
Elle ne nous fait pas peur.
Nous sommes prêts.
Je pense qu'on doublera au minimum
le nombre de députés.
Si le président de la République
veut faire du chantage, nous
sommes prêts.
Nous ne courberons pas l'échine.
On défendra les Français, quoi que
fasse le gouvernement.
- Kathia Gilder: Les députés ont
validé la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur les
réseaux d'influence étrangère et
le financement des partis
politiques.
C'était une demande du
Rassemblement National.
- On ne va pas se le cacher, on
sent une gêne de tous les groupes,
sur cette question.
C'est un droit de tirage.
Il est important que nous l'ayons.
Ca participe du bon fonctionnement
de notre rôle de contrôle.
Mais enfin, une fois qu'on a dit
ça, quand on lit le libellé, on
voit que c'est du travail...
Je ne vais pas dire que c'est du
travail d'amateurs, parce que ce
n'est pas sympathique, mais il y a
quelques critères juridiques qui
ne sont pas vraiment maîtrisés.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce qu'une
commission d'enquête peut avoir
pour but les intérêts d'un parti?
- Laurent Jacobelli: L'intérêt
national, pas d'un parti.
Faisons une enquête.
Je vois bien la gêne des autres
groupes.
Certains n'ont pas envie qu'on
creuse leurs liens avec le Qatar,
avec la Chine ou d'autres
puissances.
On verra bien ce qui en ressort.
Nous, on est très sereins par
rapport à certains partis de la
majorité ou de l'opposition, qui
ont peur qu'on fouille dans leur
financement.
- Alexandre Poussart: On se
souvient du débat
d'entre-deux-tours de la dernière
présidentielle, où Emmanuel Macron
avait dit à Marine Le Pen: "Vous
parlez de votre banquier quand
vous parlez de monsieur Poutine."
Il faisait allusion à une banque
qui affirmait avoir fait crédit au
RN.
- Laurent Jacobelli: Aucune banque
française ou européenne n'a
accepté de prêter à Marine Le Pen
et au Rassemblement National,
premier parti d'opposition de
France.
C'est déjà un déni démocratique.
Nous avons trouvé une banque qui a
accepté de nous prêter de l'argent
sous le contrôle d'une banque
française, parce que c'est la loi,
donc de manière totalement
transparente.
Tous les flux financiers ont été
contrôlés.
Cette banque a fait faillite, ce
qui montre qu'elle n'était pas
dans les mains du gouvernement
russe.
Sinon, elle n'aurait pas fait
faillite.
Les créances ont été rachetées par
un groupe industriel.
Nous avons un plan de
remboursement.
Tout cela est vérifié par les
autorités françaises.
S'il y avait la moindre
malversation, le moindre mouvement
financier suspect, comme nous
sommes le Rassemblement National,
nous aurions déjà été rattrapés
par la patrouille.
Que le président de la République
soit cohérent et qu'il mette en
place la banque de la démocratie,
dont il parlait.
Une banque qui ferait des prêts
aux candidats quand il y a des
élections.
Un président de la République qui
semble pointilleux sur les comptes
de campagne...
Il verra, j'en suis sûr, d'un bon
oeil l'enquête sur McKinsey qui
devrait avoir lieu sur ses liens
avec Uber.
- Kathia Gilder: Lundi, en séance
publique, à l'Assemblée nationale,
début de l'examen du projet de loi
qui a déjà été voté au Sénat, le
projet ENR.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi, au
Sénat, ce sera le vote sur le
budget 2023.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA